I have a friend named cava Akbar who's a
fellow poet and cava found this photo
online of the anatomical heart of a blue
whale that scientists had hung on a hook
from the ceiling which is how they were
able to observe that the heart of a blue
whale is big enough that a person can
stand up fully inside of it and when
kava shared this photo online he did so
with the caption this is another
reminder that the universe has already
written the poem you were planning on
writing and when I first saw that I was
horrified I was like come on man I'm
trying to invent new metaphors I'm
trying to discover beauty that hasn't
been discovered yet what do you mean the
universe is always gonna get there
before me and I know this isn't a
uniquely poet problem but on days when
the world feels especially big or
especially impossible or especially full
of grandeur those are the days when I
feel what do I possibly have to
contribute to all of this not long ago I
saw this video that some of you may have
seen it makes the internet rounds every
couple of months they're these birds
that are called starlings
and they fly in what's called a
murmuration which is generally just a
big cloud of birds and someone happened
to catch a quick video on their phone of
these starlings flying and at first it's
just a amorphous blob and then there's a
moment where the birds shift and they
form the shape of a Starling in the sky
and as soon as I saw it I was like the
universe has already written the poem
you were planning on writing except for
the first time it didn't fill me with
despair instead I thought okay maybe
it's not my job to invent something
new maybe instead it's my job to listen
to what the universe is showing me and
to keep myself open to what the universe
offers so that when it's my turn I can
hold something to the light just for a
moment just for as long as I have the
universe has already written the poem
that you were planning on writing and
this is why you can do nothing but point
at the flock of starlings whose bodies
rise and fall in inherited choreography
swarming the sky in a sweeping curtain
that for one blistering moment forms the
unmistakable shape of a giant bird
flapping against the sky it is why your
mouth forms on oh that is not a gasp but
rather the beginning of oh of course as
in of course the heart of a blue whale
is as large as a house with chambers
tall enough to fit a person standing of
course a fig becomes possible when a
lady wasp lays her eggs inside a flower
dies and decomposes the fruit evidence
of her transformation sometimes the poem
is so bright
you're silly language will not stick to
it sometimes the poem is so true nobody
will believe you I am a bird made of
birds this blue heart a house you can
stand up inside of I am dying here
inside this flower it is okay it is what
I was put here to do
this fruit it is what I have to offer
it may not be first or ever best but it
is the only way to be sure that I lived
at all
[Applause]